fire emblemen gauge is a deep and
rewarding tactical RPG however it has a
steep learning curve and to get the most
out of engage you need to engage with
all its systems here are 14 things you
should know before starting your
adventure
[Music]
the weapon triangle is back and it's
important to know every weapon and unit
strengths and weaknesses on the
battlefield swords beat axes axes beat
Spears and Spears beat swords simple
enough especially for long time fans but
that's only scratching the surface
physical attack Arts are strong against
magic users dagger throwers and arrow
Shooters meanwhile those Arrow shooters
or archers as some might call them are
super effective against flying units one
well-placed Arrow can easily ground a
pegasus Knight meanwhile the best way to
deal with an armored unit is to cook
them literally direct a fire-based home
at one of these units and they'll burn
alive neat spells in general are good
against armored units but in my
experience fire spells seem to be the
best taking advantage of the weapon
triangle and physical attacks also
inflicts something called break this
causes the defending unit to drop their
weapon and leave them open for another
attack of course enemies can also break
your unit so be careful keep in mind
that you can only inflict a break on an
enemy if you deal damage occasionally a
damage calculation will do zero damage
even if you have the superior weapon you
will not break your enemy
terrain can play a big role in Fire
Emblem gauge and it's important to
recognize what each tile does first of
all you can see any terrain effects in
the upper left hand corner when you've
highlighted a unit the most common
terrain type are thickets that increase
evasion and decrease Mobility most
battlefields will have forests or
something similar that will increase
evasion so it's in your best interest to
occupy those spaces and bait enemies out
of them towers are rare but they can
increase evasion and the occupying unit
will recover 10 HP at the beginning of
each turn quicksand and shallow water
will greatly hinder movement of course
flying units are unaffected by terrain
entirely they won't get the benefits or
hindrances so keep that in mind as you
command your crew
[Music]
I'm ready to dig in
I'm sorry
Sometimes the best defense is a good
defense by pressing ZL you can see the
exact range of your enemies the purple
tiles show you how far they can move and
attack as long as you stay outside that
range you should be safe I highly
recommend turning this on at the start
of each battle and leaving it on for the
entire Skirmish if you're overwhelmed by
the opposition Sometimes the best play
is to fall back and let enemies come to
you find some decent terrain to hold up
in and go on the defensive some enemies
though won't rush you until you're in
their range I typically like to lead
with a tankier unit to bait the shy
units out and then Hammer them on my
next turn
don't waste it on me fire emblemen gauge
introduces a lot of characters
especially in the early hours and any of
the characters you neglect will quickly
become irrelevant fortunately when a new
character is introduced you are forced
to use them for a battle I highly
recommend running new characters through
their Paces to see if they fit within
your core team of units because if you
forget about them it could take a ton of
careful grinding to get them up to Snuff
for example I think lapis is cool as
hell unfortunately I forgot about her
and now she's way too under leveled to
participate in any combat scenarios
there are ways I could level her up but
they require a lot of patience sorry
lapis there's another Universe where
you're the star of my Army sorting
through multiple inventories is a pain
thankfully Fire Emblem gauge lets you
auto-equip units with the touch of a
button you can do this on an individual
unit basis or before battle you can Auto
optimize your entire active team be
warned though this will remove all items
from your inactive units so if you
decide to to bring them back into The
Fray you'll need to re-equip them the
last thing you want is your healer to
roll onto the battlefield without a
staff Fire Emblem engage's class system
is deeper than ever if you meet the
proper requirements any character can
rock any class in order to pull up the
class menu press plus select inventory
then select the unit whose class you
want to change and select change class
here you can see the level requirements
required weapon proficiencies and the
item cost you'll need a master seal for
advanced classes and a second seal for
base classes once you hit max level with
an advanced class you can change into
any advanced class so long as you have a
second seal and the required weapon
proficiencies you can even use a second
seal to reset a unit's current class in
order to level it up more your stats
will stay the same if you reset your
current class but they may alter
slightly if you decide to change to a
new one it's in your best interest to
change classes once you hit max level
the worst thing you can do is let a unit
sit at level 20 for an extended period
of time so I highly recommend looking
over all the different classes and
seeing what skills come with them
[Music]
along with classes comes skills there
are five different types of skills in
Fire Emblem engage inherited which are
skills learned through emblem Rings
personal which are skills unique to that
character class which are skills unique
to that advanced class sync which are
skills tied to the equipped emblem ring
and engage skills which can only be
utilized while engaged this may sound
overwhelming but in actuality the only
skills you can really mix and match are
the inherited ones you get from emblems
still inherited skills don't
automatically equip so make sure you're
equipping skills in the inventory menu
there is a lot to do in your home above
the clouds but which activities should
you prioritize these next few segments
will tell you exactly that starting with
weapons and items weapons don't break
this time around but you can upgrade
them with money and crafting materials
technically you can upgrade just about
every single weapon in the game don't
let this overwhelm you though basic
weapons you acquire at the beginning of
the game aren't usually worth your time
or resources instead I recommend only
upgrading the unique and legendary
weapons that you will probably use
throughout the entire game as for items
make sure you're stocked up on vulneris
and staves which unlike weapons can
break after a certain amount of uses a
bit later in the game you can also
purchase Master Seals and second seals
items that are incredibly important as
you progress through the story money can
be tight in the latter half of the game
so make sure you are saving some just in
case you need to make a last minute
Supply run there are two types of rings
in Fire Emblem and gauge emblem rings
and bond Rings emblem Rings house the
spirit of a past Fire Emblem hero to
fight alongside you these rings are
unmissable and obtained as you make your
way through the story Bond rings can be
purchased with Bond fragments and give
units small stat boosts both types of
rings can be managed in the ring chamber
located next to the cafe Terrace here
units can inherit skills from emblem
Rings you can craft and combine new Bond
rings and oddly enough you can polish
your emblem Rings especially early on
it's important to inherit emblem ring
skills from Marth Makaya and Celica
there are a lot of important skills that
you'll want to learn like makaya's
healing wind this will allow a Healer to
regain some of their own health whenever
they heal another unit Bond rings on the
other hand are useful early on when you
only have a few emblem Rings you can
equip these on your emblem ringless unit
for nice stat Buffs however the further
you get the less useful these rings are
and you will probably want to save your
bond fragments for the arena after each
battle you can return to the somniels
arena and participate in three battles
for these battles you pick one unit and
that unit is pitted against another
character randomly after each battle the
unit you selected will get some
experience whether they win or lose and
the bond between those two units will
increase even if you are eager to get to
the next battle I highly recommend
stopping in at the arena that after each
Skirmish just to get some free XP it's
worth noting that the arena can't make a
low level unit viable at least not in a
reasonable amount of time if Jean is
still Level one he's probably going to
stay level one unless you bring him into
battle Additionally you can also battle
emblems in the arena however this works
a little differently by using Bond
fragments here you can increase the bond
between a specific unit and an emblem as
much as you'd like it can cost a fair
amount of bond fragments but it may be
worth it as maxing out your bond with an
emblem can take a long time otherwise
time for sure thank you for sparring
with me
resources and Fire Emblem engage are
important particularly Metals used to
upgrade your weapons the best way to get
a consistent flow of resources is by
tending to your livestock up to five
animals you've adopted can graze in the
pen the animals left out will produce
resources after each battle in my
experience dogs provide Metals I'm
assuming they just dig them up while
cats provide fish there are a bunch of
different animals that could potentially
provide a bunch of different resources
so pay close attention to which items
you find next to your animals I almost
exclusively only keep dogs in my animal
pen because I found metals to be a bit
more important than cooking ingredients
and because dogs are better there's also
a bunch of other stuff you can collect
at the somnia between battles it's
usually in your best interest to pick
everything up but this gets old fast so
I'd prioritize your animal pen and the
spring near Sami here you'll find some
extra Bond fragments if you want to Fast
Track your character's relationship with
another just give them a full load of
gifts all at like 30 pretty Pebbles that
they'll have absolutely no use for there
is no limit to the amount of gifts you
can give to a unit so if there's a
character you like a lot just shower
them with obnoxious gifts just make sure
they respond positively to your gift
otherwise you'll need to find or buy
them something else keep in mind your
character is the only character who can
give gifts this means that if you want
to increase frame and Clan's Bond they
need to fight alongside each other in
the cafe Terrace you'll find ellier's
desk here you can donate to one of the
four different countries and claim
achievements for easy Bond fragments you
don't need to return here after each
battle but it's a good idea to stop by
after a big payday or after a ton of
achievements have popped donating to
countries will give you some resources
that increase the rewards when
completing a skirmish in that country I
wouldn't blow all your money on
donations like I did because gold is
tougher to come by in the second half
but this is still important along with
support conversations Fire Emblem engage
introduces Bond conversations these are
basically the same but show characters
interacting with emblem Heroes they are
far less interesting than support
conversations but just as important as
they will increase the effectiveness
between a unit and an emblem in order to
access both types of conversations press
plus go to references and here you'll
find support and bond conversations it's
important to note that both types of
bonds can't progress until these
conversations have been completed make
sure you check out this menu between
each battle
there's 14 tips that you can take with
you when you start up fire emblemen
gauge for the first time and feel free
to leave your tips in the comments below
for more on intelligent systems tactical
RPG including my review stay tuned to
GameSpot